THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE, PART TWO.
IT SEEMS LIKE YESTERDAY WHEN THE
OBAMA GLOW APPEARED WOULD LAST
FOREVER.
>> ♪♪ I ♪
♪ AM SO IN LOVE WITH YOU ♪♪
>> Laura: I LOVE HOW HE MILKS
THE APPLAUSE AND LOOKS AROUND.
HE AND MICHELLE BECAME GLOBAL
SUPERSTARS, INSPIRED MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS AND OF COURSE THE
OTHER GLOBAL SUPERSTARS.
>> I WAS AT THE U.N. AND I HEARD
OUR PRESIDENT SAY CLIMATE CHANGE
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE
FACING NOT ONLY THIS GENERATION
BUT TO FUTURE GENERATIONS.
>> IT MADE ME FEEL HOPEFUL AND
PROUD TO BE AN AMERICAN.
♪♪ BARACK HUSSEIN OBAMA ♪♪
>> Laura: LAST NIGHT THE 2020
CANDIDATES WERE SINGING A
DIFFERENT TUNE.
WITH OUR SIGHTS TRAINED ON
JOE BIDEN, THEY DECIDED TO PICK
UP KEY ASPECTS OF THE
OBAMA-BIDEN LEGACY.
>> THIS MYTHOLOGY THAT ALL THESE
FOLKS ARE IN LOVE WITH THE
INSURANCE.
>> I'M GOING TO GO BACK TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN BECAUSE YOUR
PLAN DOES NOT COVER EVERYONE IN
AMERICA.
>> EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE, IT'S A HUMAN
RIGHT.
>> MY RESPONSE IS OBAMACARE IS
WORKING.
>> I ASKED THE VICE PRESIDENT
DID HE USE HIS POWER TO STOP
THOSE DEPORTATIONS.
>> OPEN BORDERS AS A RIGHT WING
TALKING POINT AND I'M FRANKLY
DISAPPOINTED THAT SOME FOLKS
INCLUDING SOME FOLKS ON THIS
STAGE HAVE TAKEN THE BAIT.
>> WE SAT TOGETHER IN MANY
MEETINGS, I NEVER HEARD HIM TALK
ABOUT ANY OF THIS WHEN HE WAS
SECRETARY.
>> Laura: THE CANDIDATES TRY
TO BACK OFF A LITTLE OF THAT
CRITICISM BUT THE MARKER HAD
ALREADY BEEN LAID DOWN.
>> I MISS OBAMA.
I MISS HER HUSBAND TOO.
[LAUGHTER]
HE IS OUR STATESMAN AND ANYBODY
WHO WAS AN EXECUTIVE, HE ISN'T
PERFECT.
I HOPE HE'S SITTING HERE HE
WOULD TELL YOU I MADE SOME
MISTAKES.
WE ARE HAVING AN HONEST
CONVERSATION ABOUT AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT WAS
INCREDIBLE.
>> Laura: NICE TRY, BAD JOKE.
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
EVEN THOUGH ELIZABETH WARREN
THEN BERNIE SANDERS WEREN'T AS
EXPLICIT DURING THAT FIRST
DEBATE, THEY FEEL THE SAME WAY.
AS TALENTED A POLITICIAN AS HE
WAS, AS ATTRACTIVE A CANDIDATE
AS HE WAS, BARACK OBAMA DIDN'T
DELIVER IN CRITICAL AREAS FOR
THE PROGRESSIVES.
REMEMBER WHEN HE SAID THIS ABOUT
NAFTA?
>> DO YOU SCRAP NAFTA FIX-IT?
>> I WOULD IMMEDIATELY CALL THE
PRESIDENT OF MEXICO AND THE
PRESIDENT OF CANADA TO TRY TO
AMEND NAFTA.
>> IT IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE THAT
NAFTA WAS A MISTAKE.
>> Laura: HE NEVER DID
ANYTHING ABOUT IT BUT TRUMP DID.
AND WHAT ABOUT THIS GOLDEN OLDI
OLDIE?
>> NEVER AGAIN WILL THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYER BE HELD HOSTAGE BY A
BANK THAT IS TOO BIG TO FAIL.
>> Laura: AS NOTED IN
BLOOMBERG "BUSINESSWEEK," TWO
YEARS AFTER
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA VOWED TO
ELIMINATE THE DANGER OF
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE
TOO BIG TO FAIL, AND THE
NATION'S LARGEST BANKS ARE
BIGGER THAN THEY WERE BEFORE THE
FINANCIAL MELTDOWN.
THANK GOD FOR THOSE BAILOUTS.
THEN THERE WAS THIS CLASSIC.
>> IF YOU LIKE YOUR DOCTOR, YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO KEEP YOUR
DOCTOR, PERIOD.
IF YOU LIKE YOUR HEALTH CARE
PLAN, YOU WILL BE ABLE TO KEEP
YOUR HEALTH CARE PLAN, PERIOD.
NO ONE WILL TAKE IT AWAY, NO
MATTER WHAT.
>> Laura: WE ALL SAW WHAT
HAPPENED AND WE ALL FELT IT.
MORE DOCTORS RETIRED, HIGHER
OUT-OF-POCKET COSTS, HIGHER
DEDUCTIBLES AND MANY AMERICANS
RECEIVED POLICY CANCELLATION
NOTICES.
THEN THERE WAS A TIME OBAMA
PROMISED AMERICA SHOVEL-READY
JOBS LOBBYING FOR THAT
$830 BILLION STIMULUS BILL AND A
FEW YEARS LATER, HE SAID THIS.
>> SHOVEL READY WAS NOT AS
SHOVEL READY AS WE EXPECTED.
>> Laura: I LOVE HOW THEY ARE
LAUGHING, WHAT'S A FEW BILLION
DOLLARS AMONG FRIENDS?
BIG DEAL.
FROM THE OUTSET, PRESIDENT OBAMA
PROMISED HOPE AND CHANGE AND
DEMOCRATS WERE MEMBERS
SUMMARIZED                    MS
SUMMARIZED                    ME
SUMMARIZED                    MI
SUMMARIZED                    M.
FOR ALL THE NOBEL PRIZE IN
APPEARANCE ON ELLEN, WHAT HE
DELIVERED WAS PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP.
THE LIBERAL'S WORST NIGHTMARE.
EVER SINCE, THE PARTY HAS BEEN
RISING AND VENTING, BUOYED BY
THE 2018 MIDTERMS BUT STILL
VEXED BY THE MAN WHO
ROBERT MUELLER COULDN'T TAKE
DOWN.
NOW THEY ARE FINGER-POINTING AND
ITS UGLY.
BARACK OBAMA SHOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED AT THE PARTY HAS MOVED
TO THE EXTREMES ON ISSUES LIKE
THE GREEN NEW DEAL AND
REPARATIONS -- HE TALKED A GOOD
GAME BUT REMEMBER WHEN THIS WENT
DOWN?
OR HOW ABOUT THIS?
WHEN ACTIVISTS BLAMED POLICE AND
RACISM AND IS TRAGIC DEATHS, THE
WHITE HOUSE FANNED THE
VICTIMHOOD NARRATIVES.
>> A DEEP DISTRUST EXISTS
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
SOME OF THIS IS THE RESULT OF
THE LEGACY OF RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Laura: SPEAKING OF
TROUBLING, THERE WAS THIS
PUNISHING LINE FROM OBAMA URGING
HISPANICS TO VOTE IN 2012.
>> IF LATINOS SIT OUT THE
ELECTION INSTEAD OF SAYING WE
ARE GOING TO PUNISH OUR ENEMIES,
THEN IT'S GOING TO BE HARDER.
>> Laura: THAT REMINDS ME OF
THIS.
>> YOU SEE ANYBODY IN A
DEPARTMENT STORE, AT A GASOLINE
STATION, YOU GET OUT AND YOU
TELL THEM THEY ARE NOT WELCOME.
>> Laura: OBAMA SHOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED, NO ONE SHOULD BE
SURPRISED THAT THE LEFT IS
REALLY ANGRY AND WHIPPED UP.
OBAMA HIMSELF PLANTED THE SEEDS
OF THEIR DISCONTENT.
BY THE TIME HE LEFT OFFICE, THIS
WAS A CNN HEADLINE.
TAKE IT IN.
DEMOCRATS SHOULD NOT BE
SURPRISED THAT OBAMA HIMSELF
ISN'T LIBERAL ENOUGH ANYMORE FOR
TODAY'S DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
PRESIDENT OBAMA APPEARED TO BE A
DREAM CANDIDATE BUT MANY FEEL ON